let's talk about this company Precision
Castparts and give people a sense of why
it appealed so much to warren buffett to
begin with why he was willing to pay a
21% premium to friday's closing price
yeah that's that's a great question Eric
you know you got to look at a couple of
things here this is this is a classic
Berkshire Buffett acquisition it's it's
got pretty big margins it's a company
that makes a specialized product which
means it doesn't have a whole lot of
competition so it's got one of those
moats that Buffett always looks for in a
business and then I think you you really
hit the nail on the head in the intro
there Buffett has been making this
effort over the last many years now to
build his company into something quite
different than the insurance sort of
stock-picking driven enterprise that
he's so identified with so if you look
out over the last couple of years he's
bought BNSF Railway he's built the the
energy utility business that he has they
bought a number of other more industrial
type businesses and and and really built
that part of their balance sheet and by
most you mean businesses that have
really no real competition or none
within an arm's reach yeah that's that's
the idea I mean Precision Castparts
makes these makes turbine blades they
make rivets and my understanding is that
they're not the kinds of things that an
airplane manufacturer would want to
skimp on their high quality and there's
just not a lot of competition out there
for for what they're making now is the
we talked about this a bit earlier Noah
I know you have a little more insight
into it is this shift away from
insurance on the one hand and stock
picking on the other but mostly stock
picking I would say a result of the fact
that Berkshire is just so big now it's
difficult to move the needle on the
bottom line and for that matter on the
top line without actually owning larger
and larger businesses yeah absolutely
there's without a doubt I mean how many
how many stocks could Warren Buffett go
out and invest in and put
you know 30 or more billion dollars to
work in it's just it's just not a shovel
and yeah it's a short list and and in a
couple of years ago I want to say two
years ago at the the Berkshire annual
meeting you know he called what he's
doing right now phase two for Berkshire
it's this this buying of operating
businesses and and running them for the
long haul is is is basically a different
buildup of value than than what he was
doing earlier in his career and why not
use leverage here
that's a great question he gets asked
that every year at the annual meeting
it's he's he's just a resistant to it
and you know it's it's surprising given
how low rates are but the other thing
that has to be said is that you know the
other operating units at Berkshire
spitting out cash and at the end of the
second quarter he had more than 66
billion of it on the balance sheet and
you know he's always looking for ways to
to spend that down no I was looking
through some Bloomberg data this morning
we've been calling it one of Berkshire's
biggest deals ever but by at least the
announced value going by the announced
value it is unless I'm mistaken the
biggest deal Buffett has ever announced
bigger than than Heinz for example it
sure is bigger than Heinz the the real
question comes if you're gonna include
debt in the equation the the all-in
purchase price for BNSF including debt
was was a little bit bigger but it's up
the end it was also how you measure it
it's it's it's either one or two
possibly three on the list of
Berkshire's biggest acquisitions ever
exactly exactly
no he's still got 40 billion dollars of
cash and and you and I have talked
before about how sort of quarter in
quarter out that seems to be a number
that that Buffett is comfortable with
but is that because he wants the freedom
and the flexibility to go after another
target perhaps even of this size if it
if it becomes available yeah there are
two reasons one in and and this is a
something that he says often is he likes
to keep about 20 billion on the balance
sheet because you know even though we've
been talking about Berkshire getting
away from its core insurance operations
they still under
right a lot of risk and there's a
potential for them to have to pay out
big insurance claims so they do keep a
big cash cushion always of about 20
billion for that but then yes he likes
to keep his options open you you see his
sort of classic deal playbook is waiting
for a stock to trade down or to as we
saw during the financial crisis being
able to put billions and billions of
dollars to work when other people are
fearful and the reason he can do that is
because he just keeps that huge cash
balance around no one quick thing before
we go NOAA conglomerates typically fall
out of favor right people begin to raise
questions about whether the conglomerate
structure is appropriate if there's
businesses that offer no synergy with
each other at what point is that
skepticism going to be visited on
Berkshire Hathaway I think it's gonna
happen the the moment he's no longer
around there's just no way of avoiding
that he's done a great job at convincing
people that Berkshire goes together but
the moment he's no longer there people
are going to be asking that question no